ich bin verloren man was was habe ich
hier alles bekommen was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut ich muss
sagen das video heute also ich hoffe es
wird ein cooles video ich glaube auch
das ist ein sehr cooles video werden
kann
ich muss einmal kurz zuvor story
erzählen und zwar seit ungefähr
ich bestelle ja schon immer sehr viele
sachen ich habe jetzt aber vor drei
monaten auf angefangen bei amazon hin
und wieder mal 'ne menge zu verstellen
und dann kam halt immer pakete an die
konnte ich auch eigentlich immer zu
ordnen also da wusste ich okay das habe
ich dann halt dann bestellt das brauche
ich will dass du das video über ungefähr
einem monat kam dann allerdings ein
paket habe ich so reinkommt nachzuhören
das doch gar nichts bestellt what the
[ __ ] was ist dass ich glaube das war
dieses paket hier
deswegen ist es auch schon auf ein auto
ist auch nur nur eine sache drin und
seitdem habe ich wirklich möchten sich
gegen so einen amazon paket bekommen was
ich nicht bestellt haben ich kann euch
gerne an meine amazon bestellt übersicht
hier ein bündel seht ihr was also ich
habe bestimmt drei wochen nichts
bestellt und es kommen an dauert also
nach köln zu meiner adresse die ganze
zeit so sachen weil ich habe halt noch
die ball und da dachte ich mir bevor du
das jetzt wieder zurückschickt oder
irgendwie sonst was damit machst machst
du halt ein video weil es ist
mittlerweile das sind bestimmt zehn
zwölf jahren also bevor er als direkt
loslegt und eure vermutung warum ich
dann diesen ganzen produkte bekommen in
die kommentare schreibt ich muss vorweg
sagen ich hab das schon bei instagram
gepostet und da haben sich dann auch
sehr viele leute dazu gemeldet sogar
auch leute die mal bearbeitet
gearbeitet haben aber auch leute die
juristisch aktiv sind oder so in meinem
pass auf weil wenn du das andere ist
nachher würde ich da irgendwie abziehen
oder so du musst es dann bezahlen weil
du so angenommen hat daraufhin habe ich
dann gesagt ja ich habe so viel bestellt
ich nehme immer alles an weil es kann
als sein das ist für mich als oder leute
die meinten du bist in irgendeinem promo
verteiler was ich für das
wahrscheinlichste halte und dann gab es
noch die theorie dass irgendwie fehler
im system bestehen ich hab keine ahnung
an sich ist es mir auch egal vielleicht
finden wir es eben herausgestellt hat
einfach mal mit dem auspacken und ich
bin echt gespannt ob würde tatsächlich
mal hier mit starten weil das war das
erste was ich erhalten habe und
vielleicht ergibt das ja irgendwann in
den sinn wenn nicht alles ausgepackt hat
genau das war so eine sache da der ganze
ist es halt einfach so ich muss man fast
sagen was das sind moment wir haben hier
hoch reinigungs pack für wunder glaube
ich und der markt wie hart wir raten zu
äußerster vorsicht wenn ein produkt im
ohr bereich verwendet wird nicht in das
ohr des haustiers stechen absolut also
das ist reinigung für das rohr ihres
haustiers ich habe zwar noch nie gehört
dass so etwas existiert aber ich besitze
es jetzt okay wir haben das auch schon
ich würde mal interessieren wie teuer es
ist weil dann fertig ich das halt weiter
wenn das jetzt 40 euro kostet ich glaube
es nicht aber da ist noch ganz viel mehr
als willkommen bestimmt insgesamt über
100 euro da bin ich mir fast sicher also
genau das produkt habe ich hier auf den
tempel ist nicht gefunden ich habe hier
ein anderes für 12 99 von der gleichen
marke
ich bin es euch hier auf jeden fall ein
na ja keinen namen machen wir mal weiter
danke dafür amazon das sind einfach vier
sachen drin
es ist so verrückt ich dachte halt jetzt
das hat irgendwas vielleicht jetzt auch
mit haustier zu tun und kommt alles von
der gleichen marke aber es sind einfach
die unterschiedlichsten dinge also wir
fangen hier an
wir haben hier eine neue iphone eltville
gremium template aus shenzen also es
könnte tatsächlich eigentlich auch von
uns kommen weil alles was man bei uns
bestellt kommt aus zehn cent zumindest
das meiste okay weil sollte man muss
heute das sagen ich habe ein iphone hält
seit monaten diskutieren einfach schon
schrott weil ich keine hülle tomate und
dann habe ich letztes jahr gewann davon
gesprochen dass ich ach so warte mal das
ist keine rolle das ist nur dieses
protection glas für den display
na ja besser als nichts als nächstes
haben wir hier ein speed roas zum ja
warum auch nicht nur drei meter
vorstellbar griffel eine 16 zentimeter
durchmesser 5 millimeter habe ich mir
schon immer gewünscht ein springseil und
das ist aber das ist wirklich
professionell so was hat mir früher
haben sportunterricht kommen wir zeigen
euch wenigstens einmal dass ich das gut
kann
[Musik]
ok als nächstes haben wir jede noch
avocado auch wieder made in china ich
habe gedacht vielleicht ist das gar
nicht von amazon aber doch erst amazon
logo drauf ich glaube dass hier ist so
eine beauty gesichtsmaske mit avocado
koné das ist so krämer
wie kannst du ins gesicht machen da
interessiere ich mich auf jeden fall
jetzt auf den preis moment also das
genau produkt finde ich schon wieder
nicht aber das kostet hier alles
mindestens 15 euro
gar nicht mal so günstig und dann haben
wir hier noch ein garfield mähroboter
[Musik]
okay ich habe dass ich weiß was es ist
wenn ihr so ein rasen gehabt und die
klingen von dem sind nicht mehr scharf
kann man neue bestellen ich komm nicht
gab
wir halten mal kurz fest in ein und
demselben paket war dieses iphone
protection glaubst dann das sei die
avocado maske und klingen fünf mehr
roboter weiter geht's nächstes das kann
man hier auf
hier ist tatsächlich nur ein produkt das
war schade da habe ich jetzt gedacht
dass er wieder vier stück drin sind
disneyland gmbh business ein rest lauten
ruf 23 aus essen konnte was ist das denn
nah wie nie g punkt wenn das jetzt das
ist was ich denke dann muss ich das
leider zensieren weil sonst stellt
youtube dieses video ab 18
ich habe da schon mal die erfahrung
gemacht wir machen das jetzt einfach mal
auf warum kriege ich sowas aber was man
sagen muss es ist sehr sehr hochwertig
eingepackt ist allerdings auch made in
china und ab
[Musik]
ja also die qualität davon ist glaube
ich ganz gut das muss man sagen es
handelt sich hierbei nämlich um so einen
kleinen hüpfball der hübsche und
vibriert dabei so ein scheiß warum
täglich so was ich muss jetzt hier aber
auch mal kurz erfahrung wie teuer das
ist weil das hat von premium qualität
vielleicht kann ich es weiter verkaufen
oder halt auch selber benutze alter also
ich könnte jetzt hier nicht einwenden
aber das produkt kostet 69 euro 90 das
ist doch gar nicht mal so wenig und ich
habe es umsonst bekommen okay gut mache
weiter walter jetzt ist hier wieder
moment mal kurz das kennen wir schon das
hatte ich gerade bereit so wieder diese
avocado maske genau die hat mir so gut
gefallen da haben sie sich gedacht die
schicken wir einfach noch mal dann haben
wir hier was ist das denn wie man es
benutzt wird ein frei legen sie alle
organischen verunreinigungen im
mutterbauch heilen euch fest das ist der
bifi boden tester für feuchtigkeit
sonnenlicht und ph wer so was habe ich
schon immer gesucht
schade da kostet 12 euro 15 das ist ein
bisschen wenig ok weiter geht's mit dem
sehr wichtig und selbst kleine safestick
capture the rebirth of man oder sie
ziemlich professionell auf ich dachte
hat so gar nicht mit dabei
hier ja so was kann ich eigentlich
gebrauchen kann ich doch nicht
gebrauchen
safestick sind davon immer mehr benutzer
noch sehr heftig aus weil in china da
sind die teile der absolute renner ich
gehe jetzt auch einfach mal davon aus
dass dieses ding nicht mehr als 20 euro
kostet wenn überhaupt so sogar mit
spiegel hier drin und das teil werde ich
auf jeden fall behalten weil wer weiß
für irgendwas bestimmt war gut eine
letzte sache haben wir noch was denn das
sieht aus wie so fatburning tabletten
für für frauen oder so es auf
französisch verstehe ich nicht wollen
wir hier sagen
man musste man muss das einfach auf die
haut drauf klebt und wird dadurch sind
ich bin verloren man was was habe ich
hier alles bekommen leute wenn ihr
irgendwie sowas war warum kriege ich das
und vor allem ich komme gar nicht klar
auf diese verschiedenheit der gasse
produkte die wohnung in köln haben wir
jetzt noch eine woche bis dahin können
noch weitere produkte ankommen oder halt
doch nicht ich weiß es nicht bleibt
immer gern mal eure vermutung dazu in
die kommentare was ist das alles mehr
habe ich jetzt leider gar nicht mehr das
war schon alles ich will mit meiner
freundin wir in den kanal abonniert wir
sehen uns hier am sonntag wieder am 19
uhr gibt's neues video jetzt immer
zweimal die woche dann haben wir auch
mega cool und das was mir haut rein